[Musique]
nous sommes dans l'atelier de
fabrication des casques ici il n'y a pas
de stock
la production se fait à la demande on a
fait tout à l'heure donc arretez en
cuisson et là on en vient le couvercle
enlever leurs ruches et du coup
maintenant il faut il est temps d'ouvrir
pour pouvoir la sortie en chef tout part
de ce matériel
la fibre de carbone à laquelle est
ajoutée de la résine après un passage en
cuisson chaque pièce est mise en
peinture
une peinture appliquée à l'éguille pour
boucher chaque trou de cette matière
poreuse qui est la fibre de carbone car
ici le maître mot c'est la sécurité et
la sécurité passe par le détail et la
main de l'homme
la main de l'homme c'est elle encore qui
ce truc de l'étape suivante le montage
alors on aussi on va frein faire toute
la garniture du casque intérieur donc la
mise à la taille par rapport aux clients
toutes les mousses de confort les
accessoires les toutous l'intérieur
finale du casque
les pilotes donnent leurs mesures et
leur désir en matière d'accessoires de
sécurité ou de confort
au total une trentaine d'éléments et
assemblées sur chaque casque
traite comme une caste par jour alors
cinq casques parure une cinquantaine de
salariés travaillent dans cette
entreprise
une entreprise qui équipe les plus
grands champions du sport automobile
elle a été créée il ya cinquante ont
tout juste par cet homme
boulanger au départ le boulanger de
l'époque m'emmerdait caraman passionné
de sport automobile
yves morisod crée donc d'abord une
boutique pour vendre des accessoires
automobiles puis survient un événement
qui va changer la donne j'ai vu sur le
circuit de longvic il ya eu l'accident
ou jean pierre cazé a pris feu
il a perdu le côté de la face il a perdu
les mains et l'a perdu
donc c'était ça caille était finie alors
qu'il était prêt à rentrer chez lotus en
formule 1 de quelle façon ça vous a
marqué vos cet épisode là bas parce que
je me dis faut faire quelque
chose pour ce match-là protéger les
pilotes devient donc petit à petit la
grande affaire de l'entreprise elle va
concevoir et fabriquer des équipements
avec des matériaux toujours plus
technique même pour les combinaisons
on confectionne la combinaison de a à z
c'est à dire qu'on part damon commandes
avec des fiches de mesure à la taille du
pilote
ici on court on assemble on coule un
tissu difficile à travailler
il est signé fuji pour que la vie
résiste au feu et respirant parce qu'il
fait très chaud dans une combinaison
pour les pilote de dragster jusqu'à sept
couches peuvent ainsi être assemblés il
ya aussi tous les éléments de décoration
chaque pilote soit bien sûr une
combinaison unique
l'entreprise conçoit et fabrique
également des accessoires de sécurité
dans son service de recherche
développement
voici un de ses plus grands succès le f
h
r c'est un système qui est fixée
directement au casque du pilote et qui
est retenu également par son harnais ou
sa ceinture et donc qui permet lors d'un
choc frontal de la voiture lors d'un
accident de retenir la tête du pilote et
éviter donc des lésions trop importantes
au niveau du cou au niveau de la tête
qui sont parfois irréversibles stand 21
est aujourd'hui un des leaders du marché
de l'équipement des pilotes automobiles
85% de sa production est exportée
[Musique]